graphen ist hauchdünn superleicht
trotzdem härter als diamant und
widerstandsfähiger als stahl
es leitet besser als jedes andere metall
und kann sogar zum supraleiter werden
wenn man es stark abkühlt und trotzdem
kann man es mit einem bleistift und
klebeband herstellen
graphen wurde schon oft als das material
der zukunft bezeichnet bis heute sehen
wir davon allerdings relativ wenig warum
ist das so und könnte sich das nun
endlich ändern
genau darum geht es jetzt bei doktor
watson dieses video wird gesponsort von
hello fresh die meisten von euch werden
wegen der aktuellen situation gerade das
haus nur relativ selten verlassen und
das ist im moment leider sehr wichtig
mit helau fresh habt ihr die möglichkeit
euch frisches und gesundes essen
regelmäßig nach hause liefern zu lassen
dazu will ich einfach zwischen drei
verschiedenen boxen aus und entscheidet
wie viel und wie oft ihr euch in der
woche beliefern lassen wollt dann könnt
ihr jede woche aufs neue zwischen
umfangreichen gerichten eure favoriten
auswählen die boxen werden dann
versandkostenfrei zu euch nach hause
geliefert wo ihr die rezepte dann mit
frischen zutaten einfach selbst kocht so
bleibt der spaß am kochen erhalten ohne
dass man in den supermarkt gehen muss
und außerdem hilft es sich ausgewogen zu
ernähren und vielleicht auch mal was
neues auszuprobieren
mit unserem codetwo fresh bekommt ihr
sogar insgesamt 45 euro rabatt auf eure
ersten vier boxen diesen code könnt ihr
ganz einfach bei der ersten bestellung
eingeben und erhalten dann den discount
auf eure boxen über den ersten linken in
der beschreibung gelangt jetzt zu der
auswahl von hello fresh und heft aber
noch ganz nebenbei meinem kanal
denn es mit der irre leiten 2004 haben
die beiden wissenschaftler andre geim
und konstantin novoselov etwas bisher
unmögliches getan
es brauchte lediglich etwas graphit wie
man das zum beispiel auch in einem ganz
normalen bleistift findet und eine rolle
klebeband und schon war sie da die
entdeckung und erforschung einer neuen
kohlenstoff variante die rede ist von
graphen und biografien die
wissenschaftler innen schnell die
superlativen aus es ist das leichteste
leid fähigste und lange zeit das
härteste material der welt
aber eins nach dem anderen kohlenstoff
ist aloe tropez dhs tritt im gleichen
aggregatzustand in verschiedenen
modifikationen auf ein gutes beispiel
sind diamant und graphit diese beiden
materialien bestehen aus dem selben
element kohlenstoff
das einzige was sie unterscheidet ist
wie die atome angeordnet sind
diese anordnung verdanken sie ihre
unterschiedlichen eigenschaften und
erscheinungsbilder schauen wir in das
innere dieser beiden kohlenstoff
modifikationen dann sehen wir eine
kristallstruktur das sind atome
angeordnet in einer sich endlos
wiederholen denn dreidimensionalen
struktur und genau hier tanzt graffin
aus der reihe
prinzipiell wusste man schon 1947 das
graffin existieren kann
damals ist man aber noch davon
ausgegangen dass es wegen seiner
struktur zu instabil sei um hergestellt
zu werden
denn anstatt einer dreidimensionalen
kristallstruktur tritt grafen als
honigwaben ähnliche platte in
erscheinung die atome im graffin sind
flach angeordnet sie sind quasi 2d im
endeffekt ist graffin nämlich nichts
anderes als eine einzige platte graphit
und um an dieses wunder material zu
kommen brauchten die wissenschaftler
geim und novoselov auch nur graphit und
etwas klebeband zieht man nämlich das
klebeband von einer graphit oberfläche
ab dann bleibt eine hauchdünne schicht
davon kleben sieht man wiederum darf
auch ein paar mal ein anderes klebeband
ab und löst dieses anschließend in
flüssigkeit auf dann habt ihr graphen
hergestellt
und tatsächlich gab es für dieses
scheinbar einfache experiment 2010 einen
physik-nobelpreis okay ja findet also
eine bemerkenswerte struktur so weit so
gut
aber warum kommt die wissenschaft und
industrie nicht aus dem schwärmen heraus
wenn es um graffin geht graffin ist ein
super hartes material härter ist nur
kabine
das ist eine ähnliche kohlenstoff
modifikationen die sich aber bisher nur
in einem grafen schutzmantel herstellen
lässt graffin hingegen lässt sich
theoretisch massentauglich produzieren
und ist extrem stark
es ist härter als diamant und 200 mal so
hart wie stahl
all diese aussagen muss man aber
natürlich immer in relation sehen eine
einzelne schicht graphen kann zum
beispiel nur einen fußball tragen was
aber eine erstaunliche leistung ist für
ein material das nur ein einzelnes atom
dick ist stelle ich das mal vor
seine geschichte ist für uns quasi nicht
sichtbar im fußball würde so aussehen
als würde ja vor uns schweben denn
graphen ist extrem dünn und leicht es
ist so dünn dass es drei millionen
schichten davon braucht um ein
millimeter graphit zu erhalten
und da greift ihn so dünn und leicht ist
ist es auch super ergiebig um zum
beispiel die gesamte stadt köln hiermit
graffin zu bedecken bräuchte es gerade
mal 250 kilogramm kaffee für mehr als
400 quadratkilometer das graphen dünn
und leicht ist macht es schon wahnsinnig
interessant plastik zum beispiel konnte
nie holz oder metall ersetzen graffin
schonen damit könnte man theoretisch
häuser bauen wenn man das nötige
kleingeld hat
graphen könnte durch seine stärke und
leichtigkeit aber auch genutzt werden um
neuartige flugzeuge herzustellen würde
man harte metall und plastik aus der
produktion von jets eliminieren
dann wären diese flugzeuge um einiges
leichter und bräuchten weniger
kraftstoff besonders spannend wurde es
einmal wenn es um die leitenden
fähigkeiten von graf ihnen geht
durch die flache hexagonalen anordnung
der atome bietet graffin nämlich wenig
widerstand für elektronen graffin leitet
strom effizienter als alle anderen
metalle wie zb kupfer oder aluminium
durch den geringen widerstand in der
struktur kann es aber auch dem fluss der
elektronen besonders gut manipulieren
das heißt graffin ist ein
vielversprechender ersatz für
materialien die mittlerweile an ihrem
physikalischen limit angekommen sind
silizium transistoren sind zb ein
essentieller bestandteil von prozessoren
und festplatten chips und datenspeicher
sind in den letzten jahrzehnten immer
kleiner
leistungsfähiger geworden genau so hat
es das musche gesetz ja auch vorher
gesagt seit einigen jahren ist er von
gordon moore prognostizierte fortschritt
aber immer langsamer geworden
damit zeichnet sich langfristig das ende
von immer kleineren und stärkeren
komponenten ab und genau hier kommt
graffin ins spiel
wegen seiner größe wäre graffin in
solchen komponenten platzsparend und
durch die hohe leitfähigkeit könnten
grafikprozessoren ungeahnte leistungen
erreichen
gleichzeitig bleibt graffin aber unter
hoher last kühl
sicherer ist es also auch das
wundermaterial scheint also das optimale
bauteil für den computer der zukunft zu
sein und es kommt noch besser denn mit
hilfe von enzymen ist graphen biologisch
abbaubar
aktuell muss elektronik zum beispiel
noch fachgerecht als elektro schrott
entsorgt werden
da hat die allermeisten geräte
unterschiedliche metalle oder
chemikalien verbaut haben zumindest die
lithium kupfer oder graphit können aber
durch graffin ersetzt werden und graffin
ist biologisch kompatibel
das ist wahnsinnig interessant für die
medizin und bedeutet wir könnten graffin
wahrscheinlich problemlos im
menschlichen körper nutzen solange nicht
einzelne teile abbrechen denn graffin
plättchen können extrem scharf sein und
schneiden leicht durch menschliche
zellen richtig eingesetzt könnte graphen
aber sehr nützlich sein
herzschrittmacher künstliche gelenke
oder sogar die zahnmedizin graffin
könnte eine leichtere und stärkere
alternative zu plastik keramik oder gold
sein
und das ist alles nur ein kleiner teil
graphen kann auch die luft reinigen und
salzwasser zu trinkwasser filtern
es könnte durch seine flexibilität in
niebels verbaut werden oder ein
transparentes smartphone ermöglichen
graffin scheint also ein echtes wunder
material zu sein
seit seiner entdeckung 2004 schreiben
sich wissenschaft journalistinnen die
finger wund dass graffin bald ein neues
zeitalter einläuten soll
und tatsächlich hat graffin kurz nach
seiner entdeckung riesige wellen
geschlagen
die nasa hat bis 2009 tatsächlich einen
preis ausgeschrieben für die
konstruktion eines weltraum aufzugs
natürlich mit hilfe von graphen
dieser aufzug blieb bisher aber leider
ohne erfolg und trotz des anfänglichen
enthusiasmus und ein paar prototypen
scheint das material der zukunft
irgendwie auf sich warten zu lassen denn
mein smartphone hat keine platine aus
grafing und künstliche gelenke sind
immer noch vorwiegend aus plastik oder
keramik wo ist also die grafische
revolution das große hindernis ist wie
so oft der preis dafür ist einfach
teurer als seine konkurrenz
damit sich an material durchsetzt gibt
nämlich vor allem der preis den ton an
selbst wenn graf ihn seinen job besser
als silizium plastik oder keramik macht
muss es unterm strich günstiger sein um
seinen weg in die produktion zu finden
für kohlefaser zum beispiel hat es nach
der entdeckung in den 50er jahren 40
jahre gedauert um wirklich fuß zu fassen
und selbst heute ist es in vielen
bereichen noch einen luxus material der
preis von graffin hängt vor allem mit
der aufwendigen produktion zusammen
denn während es in einem experiment zu
hause schnell hergestellt werden kann
ist eine massenproduktion bisher leider
noch schwierig hinzu kommt dass
hersteller und wissenschaftler innen
noch nicht den optimalen weg gefunden
haben graffin zu produzieren
verschiedene hersteller arbeiten aktuell
an diversen graffin basierten oder graf
ihren hybriden materialien ein
branchenstandard lässt aber noch auf
sich warten
trotzdem finde ich können wir
optimistisch sein denn langsam aber
sicher wird graffin günstiger klar die
ganzen beispiele die ich jetzt in diesem
video genannt habe sind alle noch weit
entfernt
tatsächlich kann man aber seit diesem
jahr einen ersten grafen akku kaufen da
kann schneller aufgeladen werden und
hatten mehr speicherkapazität als ein
herkömmlicher akku das ist aber noch mal
ein riesiges thema und genau deswegen
geht es darum im nächsten video und an
dieser stelle nochmal ein ganz kurzer
reminder zu hello fresh über den ersten
link unten in der video beschreibung
gibt es leckeres und frisches essen
direkt zu euch nach hause geliefert und
mit dem code to fresh sogar 45 euro
rabatt auf eure ersten vier boxen
dabei unterstützt sie unseren kanal und
ernährt euch gesund während wir alle zu
hause bleiben wie immer vielen dank fürs
zuschauen und bleibt neugierig hattrick